it's been six years now since he was
inducted into the Pro Football Hall of
Fame on the first ballot my old buddy
from NFL gameday morning back in the day
and now the host of his own podcast you
know I used to joke Warren's got a
pocket oh my gosh the knot at times you
personally happy times morning cuz you
might know there is an iron-rich and
Eisen there's three eyes in Michael
Irvin but so I had to do something to
self-promote listen okay right with this
oh no better podcast well I've been here
since day one
yes and then when they put you in too
much come on it's nothing to watch oh my
god do what he does right there's no
better host there's no better you know
I'm a sports guy for me I mean I grow it
up to you and Stuart Scott over the TV
with the booyah and different stuff that
y'all did late at night I'll be that
about Stuart when I was in high school
and my high school you said what Roger
Williams field cover me since I was in
high school so I growed up to you and
here trust me that that's that's me I
know that cable television to talk about
the University of Miami found air
conditioning and ESPN and they say that
college players don't have any perks
what do you think of that news that's
coming out here in the state of
California that that you can make money
off your name likeness and image is
California has always been at the
cutting edge I've always been like Ray
Charles says word Negro could spread his
wings and fly so California has always
been that place the land of milk and
honey
hmm I mean why wouldn't you allow these
kid O'Bannon sue them back in the day
for their likeness on the video game
correct
so there's always been California I said
to cutting-edge because why should make
save and make seven million dollars in
the kid that tears his knee I got one
for you nap on a Saturday afternoon
everyone in a college football stadium
if they get hurt we'll get workman's
comp except the players you know what
it's it are you tripped in the stands
right in a stadium they will take care
of you the kid that blows his knee out
is done he gets a scholarship cuz he
gets it so that date so who does take
care of them like the knee surgery and
stuff like that doctor for the team well
I know that but who pays for that this
Israel but then when you have lasting
injuries from this knee right here you
know long in school who takes care you
did you know I here's what I think of
sometimes you know it was I forget what
year was it Texas Michigan Rose Bowl oh
six it was right around that final Vince
Young had already been left he know he
was there this was his last year after
Vince Young that his last game at Texas
I don't believe his name is USC yeah in
the Rose Bowl and the reason why I bring
this up is because Susie now I got a
call from Braylon Edwards Oh who we knew
and said hey you know it was Christmas
Day the hotel room service was not
really working
you had Chinese food so he says he said
so Suzie's like we gotta go let's let's
get him lunch the very least so we
picked him up and Mike Hart came over to
our house and we fed them deli but on
the way to pick him up from the hotel to
go to our house there was a player for
the University of Texas uh-huh that was
walking on Santa Monica Boulevard to
walk to the McDonald's to get food it
was the late Cedric Benson oh that what
that Braylon goes and we're like that's
the star player in the Rose Bowl
walking on Santa Monica Boulevard where
there were no sidewalks to go get
mcdonalds because and and and
Ford himself and this is the whole thing
Suzanne but if said Benson had the
ability to do something for an Austin
car dealership or something how about
this though let me ask you this Warren
Sapp what if though you were there if
these rules took place down in Florida
in Miami what are we how would that have
however change the scope of things for
you and one no internet it one no social
media wasn't no army that you can carry
behind you that more people read your
tweet so your Instagram posting watch
the news or read the newspaper you know
I'm saying that's the kind of thing that
we built now so with building that we
have to spread it down to the kids
because we used to call it issue gear we
used to wear Miami the grays and the
loose right
the little shirts I mean we had no money
to go buy a polo at Dale and MA no way
no way but would it have been would it
have made it things even more
uncompetitive and tilting to the you
because that's what all the kids don't
come to you now we just got the indoor
facility we just got there we went to
Miami about Championships it wasn't
about a social media following it wasn't
about nothing we knew we playing
national championship games and we had a
chance to go 12 and oh that's what it
was about at Miami so it's 2005 Rose
Bowl yeah that was the game that put
Vince young kind of on the map and then
Vince the next year took care of yeah
see that's my memory right there Warren
Sapp here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about your 99 problems
podcast we're all podcasts are sold
you made some news sir by having Drew
Rosenhaus on your program and him saying
that people are still interested in
Antonio Brown despite everything that's
been going on here what can you have you
ever met him or non optimistic agent in
Rose house what do you mean he gets the
job done so he feels like at any point
when he gets on the phone with the team
that there's an opportunity for his
client that's how that's not that's how
you always think so some of the
criticize the call Rosa House had three
in the mine that she did't know just as
a joke because he'd always say he never
slept
you know his book shark never sleeps
bright choice to call him at 3:00 in the
morning like no like okay but that's the
kind of work
yeah I mean I had to do one time talking
about agents one time and you know I'm
like you pay your agent 3 percent right
he's like yeah I'm like I bet you can't
call him right now he's got what I'm
like call your agent right now that you
pay him 3% I'll call mine he'll answer
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed you know it
was almost like a joke for me to do this
right true but that's how he works and
that's what he believes I mean the fact
that that Brown did what he did in
Oakland and and was seen celebrating in
the back yard and then the fact that he
got a job said it again be sick Antonio
Brown you see that the the social media
has grabbed this young man and it's
feeding him because more people watch
his Twitter and his except you and him
I'm sorry
you said Larry Allen for you it's called
block a drug in this it's the social
media because I never thought a player
would pick a phone up in a locker room
in the court because there's a bunch of
naked men in this locker on
that's the last thing you want to be
doing I mean that's the first thing you
think about is somebody else's privacy
in the locker room and the last thing
you gonna do is bean this out to the
world live on Facebook hey like I'm
telling you what somebody can record it
and now save it and preserving and in
the last forever you don't do that to
your players around you and when he did
that I'm like that's something wrong and
now he goes over to Oakland running out
the back yard I don't think nobody's
giving him back that that leash that you
just saw at least for six bucks cause
you signed up so unless he walks out on
that and I mean well and that's part of
what you know Robert Clem Coe is
reporting in Sports Illustrated that led
to the second lady that comes out and
said that he he yes you said is how to
pay her for painting and then accused
him of some other unsavory behavior the
text that he then sent out that is that
include that's what this what I know you
were sick now so what so I asked you
this so what can be done it is I don't
want you home huh gone you just went to
class akley
because it's all about him and in the
National Football League is never about
one person mm-hmm
never about one person on the team so
it's definitely not about an Antonio
Brown
in the National Football League in our
100-year coupe I know I know that but
what but what about the human being and
again I know that's on him isn't it
about others around me and Dionne and
all of us from Florida safe floors we
walk around with a chip on our shoulder
yeah so we know where the line is did
you look not to cross mm-hmm he's
crossed that line he's crossed that line
went on the run now skidding and sliding
all the way down so do you that two
things here do you think he'll play in
the NFL again no okay
and two do you think he will get the
help that you think he needs do you
think including your podcast he couldn't
tell me what to do but I knew the line
would you not the cross if maybe that
line has gotten blurred and some people
around him whoever this is somebody need
to grab the young man and sit him down
and say Sonny this ain't the way to go
about this you could have made a hundred
million dollars in the next five years
easily you had a first-ballot Hall of
Fame career running at it for the last
seven years what the hell are you doing
you don't want to go to walk through
when I walk to walk through rich and it
Marinelli sitting there be like James
can I need a little work today
practice right walk out on the field
just like everybody else with my
Gatorade in hand you have my ship Canada
get in there that's what the backup is
for when you're not feeling right you
take walk do I got practice let's go
Warren Sapp here on the Rich Eisen show
is Dee Brooks gonna hear the perfect
case you know what I didn't call him
it's okay I'll give you at the word
because the doom is one of the most
fares guys I know but when you have a
record it's kind of tough so do you
think it's a fair suspension from the
NFL to say get out for the rest of the
year to vantes perfect Warren Sapp I
think he's had more than thirty thirteen
suspension two for illegal heads
I think I think that your resumes fit
the resume fits and for some reason
that's talking to you and finding you
really doesn't do it so we don't take
the game you love away from you maybe
that will make some reactions on your
browser don't take the game away from
you and see how your reaction is what is
the reaction by other players like let's
just say we're we're one of your
teammates was hit dirty and there's a
player that's out there that has this
reputation has this resume and a lot of
folks are saying that the NFLPA should
be the one to come out and say let's
let's sit him down for the year or two
but don't leave it up to the NFL what do
you say to that Warren that players
because of the PA gets paid to be on the
players side so he's like the crazy
agent that thinks she's gonna get him
back in the league he has to be SP that
way but at the pond the player the
players may be but the players in the in
the in the huddle yes me Lynch Brooks we
wouldn't tolerate that on that defense
how so you're not finding cheap shot
nobody mm-hmm this game is a game a
calmer this game is the most humbling
game on God's green earth it will come
back at you in a way that you ain't
never seen before we should call it a
dirty game right back at you
cuz I mean that's just what happens in
football if you go after somebody it's
coming back it's definitely coming back
and your teammates might help set you up
for it cuz you're wrong for that dog
you're just wrong for that we don't play
the game like that this is not about
hurting somebody this is a great game
that's gonna be played for a long time
we just got to take care of each other
and wonderfully knows that Warren Sapp
here on the Rich Eisen show and now so
you were with Ray Lewis last night and
Dancing with the Stars but my books on
Sunday but it's about to say your
weekend began with the Bucs dropping the
double nickel you know I told you five
five and ninety nine go well he does
baby burger and mooching y'all were
doing the game we were watching y'all
look at that Jackie Slater on mix you
know mostly I told me come up to the
thing so I sent my picture of my pool
pool bucks is on five is twenty eight to
fourteen of my boys with the work so who
are the Bucks what we saw this week or
assessed to me what the first four games
and the Bruce Arians and having James in
his
since week one after throwing the to
pick six because when you look out in
the priests snap reading this Richard
Sherman on the running back and the
running backs not running a slant you
don't throw it out there and then you
throw a pick six on on a screen I think
Byron Leftwich and coach finally got
torn the hey come out way wood will show
you but then we get in the game and I
dam kick returner wants to return
there's no more kick returns in the NFL
nobody can anybody get that through they
just catch the ball to me look down
they're giving you five the ology on the
25 what is the problem he wants to
return the ball on the 10 yard line with
back and I'm a quarterback is under
duress he throws a pick that's when it
happens whenever our special teams and
everybody don't come together for Jamis
but everything when he's when
everything's moving on track he's a
great quarterback I love what he does
but the Bucks has got to figure out a
way to just slow down them all defense
that defense I know I mean Daniel Jones
was born into the league in a in a
spectacular fashion so in Week three and
then golf threw for five hundred yards
but you do have the right guy
coordinating there to fix it right and
bulls would you agree or were you yeah I
like both I like boses whole attack mode
when he put the five down linemen on
first down I said license to kill rich
in the National Football League
everybody doesn't want to watch hey sue
pick that one ticket to the house and my
books are two and two we right behind
the Saints and true reason coming back
for another month so we all right yeah
now well I shouldn't that's your next
game man oh yeah yeah I was thinking
about going to knowledge I was thinking
about going down the knowledge that give
me some broad crawfish at the acne and
see what's going on oh are you in sue
okay cuz I do remember on occasion on
game day morning you would speak your
ninety-nine mind about him I'll tell you
this I've been inside the building I
went to go get my knee trading that I
sold the other thing okay
he reached over and said excuse me and
grabbed his helmet that's the only thing
you said to me since we won't show time
together that's it that's it would you
want to have a relationship well now we
go
[Laughter]
[Music]
warrants ampere and the Rich Eisen show
who do you want on your pod you've had
Gurley Jonathan Abram who I'll be like
I'm like boy we to put you right in the
box and Lynch or you over the top and
Lynch in the box
crying that's that stream days with a
kid like that and he loves the game oh I
love that kid he is great I love it I
know Mayock picked a winner right there
Jacobson that kid that was gonna be son
of us come a dime a dozen two nickels
every time I told you this right yeah
that's what nothing go ahead and show
back up to work cause they're running
for more yards now than they did last
right and you got Brooks who do you want
on your pod more you know I'm taking to
eight come on back to talk about right
now I just had Franco going the
University of Miami the other hurricane
Hall of Famer we're done with it now I
mean the guy ran for 100 yards against
the New England Patriots roll your eyes
all you want Chris Paul play it's gonna
be Emmett
Franklin going it I'm 10 I'm not gonna
argue with Warren but name your
quintessential Frank Gore moment you can
tell the story the NFL without Frank
Gore I don't know man you have to talk
about the top five running backs of all
unit by the way you're not looking at
Warren when you say that why are you
looking at me I'm in the Hall of Fame
and I don't want to spit on nobody go
jackets but there's a couple go jacket
at the NFL could be told without their
names to so relax
I'm fine with the being in but you know
we put the 55th all-time leading rusher
which one is that again look it up I
said Gayle sayers is it uh Shh okay I
don't understand anymore
born in this case some guys don't
deserve to be what's it like being in
that room for the for the Nitschke
luncheon again for those who don't know
it's the Friday that kicks off the
weekend we're all returning Hall of
Famers it's a it's a gold jacket
required gold jacket only room yeah and
you get in there and you welcomed in the
new class by letting them know they're
still they're rookies again for just one
more year can I say it can't say a word
right can I say it word you gotta sit
there what's deacon still alive when
you're in no unfortunately and Willie
Lanier started the meeting Bruce Smith
kind of took it over mmm somebody else
had something to say and then Michael
Irvin kind of brought it home my year
right and every year has been a little
different a little change I still have
yet to speak in the Ray Nitschke
luncheon you have yet to speak it's just
you've been in there six this is your
sixth year being in there you've yet to
speak in there yes because every year
I've came back somebody else wanted to
say something cuz my class was Parcells
and Larry Allen Chris Carter you know
saying a nice class you know with
Jonathan Ogden
yeah and Dave Robinson and Curley cop
who waited 27 and 30 years of peace mmm
so I just sit back and shut up I talked
enough just got on my Erin told me the
55th time you said it everyone's gonna
look it up thank it that's that's why
they do that don't do that great friend
of the show oh my gosh yeah yeah oh no
why not because it's a Terrell Davis won
two championships can be told on it okay
they didn't say this one's for Terrell
they said this one's for John James got
12 almost 13 thousand yards come on in
Frank Gore got over 15 and he over here
being a real snob about it really don't
do that in rich I like Teddy set up in
ya know last thing here know last thing
you know just coming back to the
hurricane and
Jim Brown is the goat can we please stop
yelling all these other goats well I
mean Jerry Rice they refer to him the
great his receiver Walter okay say that
the greatest but is Ginebra now you were
at the you o played next to Dwayne
Johnson mother play behind me he played
behind he was on the sideline when I was
on the field like he's in the movies and
I'm not on losing so it was never Warren
Sapp and Dwayne Johnson next to each
other on the line never once you never
rush the passer together not that I can
remember hmm okay once or twice but no
but you took his job though right did
you take it never a depth chart with
Dewey above me only at the University of
Miami if you can find one let me know
Dewey is that how you refer to him do
sorry well this I mean he was the start
of the year before and then you came and
it was never too started at the
University of Miami mark Caesar was it
started in the year before that was
Anthony Hamlin in the Eric Miller then
why does this story get told like that
because he's in Hollywood and you make
[Laughter]
trouble following the script at that
so was the last time you saw it's been a
long time that's it that means it's a
long time since I love college come on
really I thought you guys were story he
went to the Argonauts and whatever's on
his last leg eating poking beans and
weenies and totally chef get your down
up and get motivated and warrants I took
your job and all this I thought you know
what I'm not waking up at 4:30 in the
morning going to the prize gems we'll go
live with him and now he has a lid
and everything in the family in new
Africa now go ahead do you thing is
wonderful I love watching the movies
love wow he's great in them
he's great movies I would love one to
come back to the University of Miami
like when we played the Florida to
kick-off okay he's not there why he's
working he's busy
really yes he's like the hardest working
guy I needed you to Kevin Patrick
enquire and let them okay that was those
are the guys used to read real with real
tight with oh is that rattle yeah that
was his boy okay yeah yeah all right so
a rock or sooo who would you prefer to
have a relationship with I have a
relationship with Dwayne okay we okay
good good wonderful to and to love us
looking good was throwing the ball here
I was amazing that was that listen maybe
the best game I know Jameis is thrown
four touchdowns in the dome to kick off
a season to beat the Saints and I
understand that I thought that was one
of the the best game I've ever seen
Jameis play played one he played this
past weekend yes he played he was on
it's tough to stop only Sunday stepping
up in the pocket moving shake and put
the ball on oh yes everything he he was
the Jameis we remember him always why he
was the number one pick correct that's
what we supposed to see I think Byron
Leftwich is really calmed him down to
where you don't have to do it all son
you have some people around you so
allowed them to work for you and you
never go broke making a profit
good to see Warren Sapp always great to
see thanks hey man I got to get you one
of my beers you know barrel of monks
made me a 99 beer no there's a Belgian
blonde but we only serve it in Florida
so I'm gonna have the ships on my head
least a mile ship your case make sure
you get him dead drunk and let him watch
some Frank Gore tape man don't go to
throw up y'all my cans got almost 30,000
yards with the rushing in the National
Football League and you're telling me
neither one I'm dessert
be in the hole that's not what I said
you did you implied it strongly warren
sapp on Twitter and Instagram I follow
him you should have 99 problems podcast
I do have a million now yeah and I
always want to tell you to name your
Twitter account at Warren Sapp who is
that person yours the Joslin rich Ivan
told me to put my face up this is yours
make it personal do not be playing
around what is that s thing up there
yeah it was and I'm like great I know 99
podcast check it out we're all podcasts
are gotten up when we come back for the
TV audience Deion Sanders had a great
week picking games and by great I mean
prime if you're sitting there and your
job and your bubble bath yeah it's gonna
be on well off when we come back for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app